as Colombian president Gustavo Petro
called for Global Peace at the U.N he
received very welcome news about the
conflict at home
after months of setbacks of [__] Rebels
dissident group called The estado Mayor
Central or EMC agreed to begin formal
peace talks on October 8th the two sides
said they were abide by a 10-month
ceasefire
the mayor of estrado central of the farc
EP and the government will start a
ceasefire by ordering a suspension of
offensive actions and the installation
of a monitoring mechanism together with
the process of protecting the civilian
population
Petro has ambitious plans to bring peace
in the country there are ongoing
negotiations with another group The eln
Colombia's largest remaining Rebel group
he is seeking deals with all armed
groups and crime mafias to finally bring
a complete end to a six-stecade internal
conflict that has killed more than 400
000 people
but most of his attempts have failed so
far with violence increasing in many
regions armed groups are fighting for
control of lucrative drug routes and
illegal mining
the EMC was founded by former farc
Rebels who rejected the 2016 historic
peace deal signed by that group attempts
at previous ceasefires failed when the
EMC murdered four indigenous teenagers
but now they're announcing several
gestures of good faith promising to not
interfere in upcoming Regional elections
and by releasing hostages
we want this message to be interpreted
in a positive way we want to demonstrate
that the farc is committed to building
peace with social and environmental
justice bringing to the negotiating
table dissidents groups that had
rejected previous attempts at peace was
one of the government's biggest
challenges and it represents real
progress for Petro's ambitious goals for
now it's just a start but one that
represents a much needed relief for
thousands of Colombians still caught in
the crossfire of this ever mutating
internal conflict Alessandra Al Jazeera
Bogota